[Music]  look for the joker he's got it now down  to three  at two  jokic out to morris a three to win and  he got it  denver wins it at the buzzer  the  [Applause]  he kicks it back out and mate morris  hits a three to win the game  [Applause]  that's who jokic is the player  unselfish  the defense is going to sell out to him  [Applause]  the defense just collapses  he kicks it back out  pretty good look  it wasn't bryn forbes but it was denver  going for the three in the  [Applause]  they walk-up it to make sure it was  before the clock it was that it was a  three it was  and the denver nuggets had trailed for  essentially 47 minutes in the game win  in a walk-off  as the joker  makes the right play and morris hits the  three that's a tough one because if  you're stepped there you got to think  joking is going to shoot it so he  committed the jokic came off of monty  morris and celebration for the nuggets  welcome to the western conference tough